>> Welcome to the YouTube Direct Deployment
Walkthrough. We'll start with the YouTube
API developer registration. If you don't already
have a Google account, you could create one;
otherwise, log in with your existing Google
accounts credentials. After logging in, you'll
be taken to the developer registration form.
The organization name and country fields are
mandatory. The other fields are optional.
Take the time to look through the YouTube
API Terms of Service and after doing so, check
the "I agree to the terms and service above"
box and click "Register".
After registering your account, you'll launch,
"Register a New Product." Enter a name for
the product and, optionally, the Web site
and description of that product. Then click
"Save" to generate a developer key. Next,
we'll cover Registering with App Engine. Log
in with your existing Google account. If this
is your first time using App Engine, you might
be asked to verify your account; otherwise,
click the "Create an Application" button.
Chose an Application Identifier for your new
App Engine Instance; this will be part of
the URL that you use and access the administration
panel. Take a look through the App Engine
Terms of Service, when you're done, check
"I accept these terms" and then click "Save."
Congratulations, you now have an App Engine
Instance. The dashboard link will give you
more information about your App Engine Server.
The next step is to Download the Eclipse Development
Environment. From the Downloads page, select
the Eclipse IDE for Java EE Developer's link.
Download the file through your local mirror.
This may take some time depending upon the
speed of your internet connection. Once the
download is complete, you'll need to uncompress
the archive file and then you can open up
the Eclipse application. If this is your first
time using Eclipse, you might want to visit
Eclipse.org or use the online help to learn
more about the program. Next, we'll walk through
installing some Eclipse Plugins. From the
help menu, chose Install New Software.
The Google Plugin for Eclipse Web page has
a URL to use to install the plugin with Eclipse.
Well, copy this URL to the clipboard. Back
at Eclipse, click "Add" then enter Google
Plugin for the name and paste in the location
of the plugin. You'll see a list of different
plugin components; though the version numbers
may not match what you see here. Select them
all and then click "Next." Read through and
accept the license agreement and then click
"Finish." After installation, click "Yes"
to restart your Eclipse environment. We'll
now go through the same process; this time
for the Subclipse SVN Plugin. Visit the Subclipse
Web site to get the Eclipse update site URL,
and copy it to the clipboard. Go back to Eclipse,
click "Add" and then enter Subclipse for the
name and paste the URL into the location.
Select all the components and then click "Next."
Click "Next" again. Read the license agreement
and indicate your acceptance, then click "Finish."
Next stop is SVN Checkout. From Eclipse, go
to "Window", then "Open Perspective" and then
"Other." Chose "SVN Repository Exploring"
and then click "Ok." Visit the source tab
of the YouTubedirectcode.google.com page to
get the URL to check out from SVN. Back in
Eclipse, right click the SVN Repositories
Panel and chose New Repository Location. Paste
in the URL. Expand the new SVN Repository
and right click on the YTD subfolder. Choose
"Checkout." You could keep the default settings
and YTD will be checked out and some project
in your current Eclipse workspace. Let's run
a local App Engine Web Server. Switch back
into the Java EE perspective. You'll notice
that Eclipse says there's a Google App Engine
problem. This has to do with the missing configuration
file that we'll soon take care of. From the
YTD project, find the "War" subfolder and
then the "Web Info" subfolder underneath that.
Right click on the "App Engine Web default
XML File" in this folder and chose "Copy";
then right click and chose "Paste." Name the
new file appengine-Web.xml. Right click this
new file and choose "Open with Text Editor."
There are several changes we need to make
to this file. First, we'll enter the name
of the App Engine Instance in the application
XML tab. Next, we'll copy our YouTube API
Developer Key and paste it into the document
as well. Storing the Developer Key in this
document will ensure that it's always available
to our App Engine Application whether it's
running on the local server or a deployed
instance. Let's also enter value for the YTClientID
element. This value could be anything we want
and let's use this unique identifier when
we make a request. After saving our changes,
we're ready to run our Web application in
the local App Engine Server. By default, this
Web server will run on your current machine,
host name, local host, and Port 8080. If you
visit that address from a Web browser on this
current machine, you'll be able to see with
blankindex.html file. If you visit /admin,
you'll be able to see the admin panel. There's
no user authentication on the Development
Web Server, so you just log in as an administrator.
We'll now cover YouTube Account creation.
If you don't already have a YouTube account,
we're going to walk through the steps in creating
one. If you do already have a YouTube account,
please make sure that it's linked to the Google
account that you use to register your YouTube
Developer Key. Your YouTube account will contain
playlists that are automatically generated
for each assignment you create. When you approve
a video submission from the assignment, it
will be automatically added to each playlist.
When creating a new YouTube account, fill
in the request information, read the terms
of service and then create the account. At
this point, we'll link our existing Google
account to our new YouTube account. Now that
our YouTube account is created and properly
linked, we go back to the local Web server,
to the configuration panel and associate our
YouTube account with our YouTube Direct Instance.
We'll now cover App Engine Deployment. The
Google Plugin for Eclipse makes deploying
to App Engine easy. Just click on the App
Engine icon in the toolbar. Enter your email
address and password for your Google account
and then click "Deploy." The plugin will take
care of packaging all your source code, uploading
it to the App Engine Servers and starting
up a new JavaServer environment. Once the
deployment is complete, you could visit it
on Web from any machine. The URL will be the
App Engine identifier you registered earlier,
.appspot.com/admin. You'll have to log in
with your Google account that you use to create
the App Engine Instance. If you to permit
additional Google accounts to login, you could
do so from the App Engine dashboard; add additional
accounts as developers to your App Engine
instance. Next stop is AuthSub Registration.
AuthSub is Google's technology for delegating
access to Google or YouTube accounts. Unless
you register your domain in advance to use
AuthSub, you and your users will see a warning
message when trying to log in. To register,
visit www.google.com/accounts/ManageDomains.
Once there, enter the host name of your App
Engine Instance and then click "Add domain."
Click on the link that appears at the bottom
to be taken to the next step on the registration.
After logging in again, you'll be presented
with information about verifying your domain.
We'll register by copying this metatag and
pasting it into the index.html file for our
App Engine Instance. Paste it within the head
element of the HTML document. Save your changes
and then redeploy your App Engine Instance
to production. After your code is redeployed,
go back to the verify ownership page, and
click on the "Verify" button. Take a look
through the terms of service, and when you're
done, click on the "I agree to the terms of
service" button. On the next page, enter your
App Engine Web site's full URL, starting with
HTTP in the target URL path prefix field.
It's very important that you don't use HTTPS
as the URL prefix. Click "Save" when you're
done. If you completed the steps properly,
you should be able to go back to your production
App Engine Instance, go to the configuration
tab and authenticate. The warning message
should be gone and you could click "Allow
Access." Let's focus on YouTube Direct Configuration.
Your YouTube API setting should all be filled
in at this point. Video Branding Settings
control what tags and descriptions are shown
in videos that are approved by your YouTube
Direct Instance. Mouse over the question mark
for more information about any setting. The
Moderation/Submission Settings control whether
videos need to be exclusively approved by
your editors, whether you accept new and existing
videos or just new videos and notification
emails, like you receive for new submissions
and it get automatically sent out to submitters
when their videos are moderated. You need
to make sure that the email address you use
is registered as a developer for your App
Engine Application. Otherwise, App Engine
will refuse to send email using that address.
YouTube URL and Article URL will be replaced
by actual URLs when your emails are sent.
This way, recipients will know exactly which
YouTube video and article the email refers
to. The Submission Widget Settings let you
control the HTML that is displayed before
users submit videos and the post-submit thank
you message. Once you're done, click "Save
Changes." The next step is Assignment Creation.
Go to the Assignments tab and click "New Assignment."
The categories correspond to YouTube video
categories. An active status means that new
submissions will be accepted. A description
will be used for the YouTube playlist. After
clicking "Create," you'll see the new assignment
show up in the list. The embed button will
display code that you could use to solicit
YouTube direct submissions from your Web pages.
This code is generic and you might want to
end up customizing it to suit your specific
purposes. For now, let's copy it and paste
it into a new HTML document to illustrate
how it could be used. We'll create the new
page in Eclipse and end up deploying it along
with our production App Engine Instance. Once
we've created the new file, we'll put in a
simple HTML structure. We'll copy the embed
code from the admin panel and paste it in
into the body element of our new page. Once
that's done, we click on the App Engine Button
on the toolbar. Save changes and deploy your
code to App Engine. Now that the codes are
deployed, let's visit the page in your App
Engine Instance.
The page will have the default graphics and
layout, but you're free to customize the code
to suit your needs. Clicking on the "Submit
your response" called action (ph) image will
load up the submission widget. Under the hood,
an Iframe is created on your Web page that
loads content from your App Engine Instance.
Clicking on login will take the user through
the AuthSub authentication flow. When the
user clicks "Allow access," this generates
an authentication token that YouTube direct
can use to upload videos into their account.
Clicking "Upload a Video" will initiate the
user upload flow. That brings us to Moderating
Submissions. After receiving a submission,
we'll see it appear within the submissions
tab of the admin panel. If you've configured
email notifications of new submissions, you'll
also see it in your email account. The email
will contain a link to the actual YouTube
video, the name of the YouTube user and the
assignment ID for which the video was submitted.
Back in the submissions tab at the admin panel,
you can click "Details" next to the submission
to find out more information about the video.
Assuming the video has been processed and
accepted by YouTube, you could play a video
preview here. Once you're ready to moderate
the video, click "Unreviewed" in the status
column and chose approved or rejected. You
could also choose Spam. Press return to save
your changes.